Hello everyone,
thank you for tuning into the lane focus
channel.
My name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Fsi free courses
that are available online.
So what does the Fsi that is the foreign
service institute and that is where
American diplomats or foreign service
workers do their intensive language
training before they are placed abroad.
Now why does that matter to us to
language learners?
Will it's because the Fsi materials,
at least the older Fsi and materials
that they use for their intensive
language study are available in the
public domain and you can get them on
the Internet for free.
So that's very relevant to us.
Anything that's free makes us pay a
close attention,
doesn't it?
Well,
you can also get them in hard copy
format.
You can get some repackaged versions
like this.
This one is called mastering Hebrew,
but this is actually the Fsi Hebrew
course.
Just some,
uh,
some entrepreneur repackage them and
decided to sell it.
I also have this one mastering French
and I have this one which is called.
It's just Saudi Arabic.
This is the Saudi Arabic of course from
the FSF.
So you can buy them in hard copy format
if you are willing to spend some money,
if you want the free one or if you want
to try them,
then they're public domain,
find them on the Internet and I'll give
you a link where you can find them
later.
So let's talk a little bit about the
pros and cons of these FSI materials.
First of all,
the pros,
the first thing is there are free.
So how can you go wrong with free
materials?
Even if they suck,
then you stopped using them and you've
lost nothing,
right?
So you can download them,
try them out,
see how it goes.
They're free.
What more could you ask for?
The second thing is that they are quite
dense courses.
There is quite a lot of material that
you can use that you can get through
there.
The Hebrew one is about 550 pages.
The French one,
well this is only one quarter of it
right here on this in this volume,
but this is 250 pages.
It's altogether,
it's 900 or a thousand pages and the
Arabic one is 250 pages,
so there's quite a lot of material for
you to use and there's hours and hours
of audio to go with it,
so it's just a lot that you can use.
If you do work through that material,
you'll gain a good working knowledge of
the language that will probably also be
very good for your sentence level
fluency because they just drilled the
hell out of you.
There are so many drills in these
courses and there are question and
answer drills,
substitution drills,
transformation drills,
just drills,
drills,
drills.
Not all the time but a lot of the time
and it really helps you just spit out
the sentences more quickly.
It really helps improve your fluency and
to produce sentences on the go when you
need to so you don't have to spend as
much thinking time to produce your
sentences.
After finishing the FSI Hebrew course,
there was a huge jump in my fluency.
I could produce sentences much more
rapidly.
I actually studied with the Fsi course
between two trips to the Middle East.
On the first trip I couldn't really
produce sentences very quickly and on my
second trip there,
after using the Fsi course,
everybody told me,
wow,
you speak like a native speaker.
I guess they're flattering me a little
bit,
but basically doing so many drills
helped me to to speak fluently and
without lot of pausing and hesitation.
They're also good because the language
presented is based on everyday common
situation.
Things like meeting someone for the
first time,
ordering a ticket at the station,
inviting someone out,
that kind of thing,
talking about the weather.
Those are the way they introduce the
language at the beginning of the lessons
and then after that they expand upon
that by drilling the hell out of you,
but they introduced the language using
those common situations so everything
you learn is quite useful and relevant
and it's thematically based in each
chapter,
so that helps you remember all of the
new material you're learning now for the
cons or the bad.
These courses are mind numbingly boring.
At least some of them and at least at
times they can be really,
really drill intensive and I remember
sitting there in the middle of these
courses sometimes just counting down the
minutes saying,
okay,
10 more minutes,
I'm almost done,
and just praying for the end because
they really are boring.
You need to be motivated yourself.
These courses will not motivate you.
They're really dry a lot of the time and
you just have to push through them and
that requires you to bring your own
motivation to the table.
Another downside is that the audio
materials are just not that high quality
because they were produced in the 19
sixties and seventies quite a long time
ago and the new cds that you might get
are still based on those original master
tapes.
So sometimes they're not clear,
they're a bit fuzzy and they're just not
really.
They're not really as good of a model as
a digital audio recording would be a
modern recording,
so I would recommend that if you do use
these Fsi materials,
you get some other more modern digitally
recorded audio materials so that you can
copy the pronunciation of a native
speaker clearly.
Right.
Another downside is that these courses
are not really made to be used as
standalone materials.
They're made to be a manual for a
classroom course that is taught by an
instructor and the instructor in these
courses is supposed to give you extra
activities that help you get more
interactive experience and sometimes in
some of the books you can see notes to
the instructor like,
please do this,
please prepare an activity for this
purpose and that kind of thing.
But obviously those activities are not
in the book.
They were up to the instructor of the
classroom course.
So these books don't come with a
You have to get that experience,
that extra component that the teacher
would be responsible for.
You have to get done on your own,
so really you need to just get
experience communicating and interacting
with native speakers.
You need to take some lessons.
You get to talk with friends who speak
that language,
just do that in addition to these
courses,
so in conclusion,
most people find these Fsi courses
really just too boring to drill
intensive,
but I do marginally recommend them for
people who are just having trouble with
fluency and having trouble with sentence
structure.
People who take a long time to think
about their sentences and piece them
together.
If you want to gain that automaticity,
that fluency,
then you want to just practice with some
drills.
These are really good for drills.
That's basically the main thing I
recommend them for and if you want to
just be able to spit out sentences more
quickly than by all means try these out.
Check out their drills,
but bring your own motivation to the
table because these are boring and also
just be prepared for some unclear audio.
Don't expect 2015 level audio quality
for because you won't get it.
So supplement with some other audio that
you can model your pronunciation after.
Thank you for tuning into the length
focus channel.
Have a good night.
Talk to you later.
Something that has been all the rage
recently,
something called duo lingo.
Now this is a totally free language
learning platform.
It has a online desktop version and also
a smartphone version.
It's quite good.
Um,
I like it,
but I think it's quite expensive and
that seems to be one of the common
complaints is just the price.